so we draw the x axis and name it x dash
x
we draw the y axis and name it y dash y
how do we number the axis
until now we have only seen cases where
we have numbered this side of the x-axis
and this side of the y-axis
one two three four and so on on the
x-axis
and one two three four and so on on the
y axis
the reference point or the origin is
zero
on the left hand side of the horizontal
axis just like the number line we mark
negative natural numbers minus 1 minus 2
minus 3 minus 4 and so on
similarly on this side of the y axis
we mark minus 1 minus 2 minus 3 minus 4
and so on
remember all these are marked in equal
intervals
now let's take a random point somewhere
on the plane and try to give it an
identity
say we have a point p here
it is three units away from the origin
on the horizontal axis
and two units away on the vertical axis
how do we denote the point then
we write it as 3 comma 2 inside round
brackets
that's the identity of point p
but in mathematics we do not refer to it
as an identity
we call these the coordinates of point p
3 is the x coordinate and 2 is the y
coordinate
here's something you really need to know
this is not the same as 2 comma 3.
2 comma 3 will be this point here
2 units away on the x axis
and 3 units away on the y axis
the order matters
hence they are called an ordered pair
the value on the x-axis is always
written first and then we write the
corresponding value on the y-axis
this entire system is called the
cartesian coordinate system
we will soon learn more about it